recently we've seen the effects of cyber
attacks on the business world data
breaches of companies like JPMorgan
Yahoo Home Depot and target have caused
losses of hundreds of millions and in
some cases billions of dollars it
wouldn't take many large attacks to
ravage the world economy and the public
sector has not been immune either in
2012 to 2014 there was a significant
data breach at the US Office of
Personnel management's security
clearance and fingerprint data was
compromised affecting 22 million
employees and you may have heard of the
attempts by state-sponsored hackers to
influence use stolen data to influence
elections outcomes in a number of
countries two recent examples are the
compromised of a large amount of data
from the Bundestag the national
parliament of germany and the theft of
emails from the US Democratic National
Committee but the cyber threat is now
affecting our democratic processes and
it's likely to get worse as computer
computer technology is becoming more
powerful the systems we use to protect
our data are becoming more vulnerable
adding to the concern is a new type of
computing technology called quantum
computing which leverages microscopic
properties of nature to deliver
unimaginable increases in computational
power it's so powerful that it will
crack many of the encryption systems
that we use today so is the situation
hopeless
should we start packing our digital
survival gear and prepare for an
upcoming data apocalypse I would say not
yet quantum computing is still in the
labs and it will take a few years till
it's put to practical applications more
important there have been major
breakthroughs in the field of encryption
for me this is a particularly exciting
time in the history of secure
communications
about 15 years ago when I learned of a
newfound ability to create quantum
effects that don't exist in nature
I was excited the idea of applying the
fundamental laws of physics to make
encryption stronger really intrigued me
today a slick a select group of
companies and labs around the world
including mine and maturing this
technology for practical applications
that's right we are now preparing to
fight quantum with quantum so how does
this all work well first let's take a
quick tour of the world of encryption
for that you'll need a briefcase some
important documents that you want to
send your friend James Bond and a lock
to keep it all safe because the
documents are top-secret we're going to
use an advanced briefcase it has a
special combination lock which when
closed converts all the text in the
documents to random numbers so you put
your documents inside close the lock at
which point in time the documents get
converted to random numbers and you send
the briefcase to James while it's on its
way you call him to give him the code
when he gets the briefcase he enters the
code the documents get unscrambled and
voila
you've just sent an encoded message to
James Bond a fun example but it does
illustrate three things important for
encryption the code we call this an
encryption key you can think of it as a
password the call to James to give him
the code for the combination lock we
call this key exchange this is how you
ensure you get the encryption key
securely to the right place and the lock
which encodes and decodes the document
we call this an encryption algorithm
using the key it encodes the doctor text
in the documents to random numbers a
good algorithm will encode in such a way
that without the key it's very difficult
to unscramble what makes encryption so
important is that if someone were to
capture the briefcase and cut it open
without the encryption key and the
encryption algorithm they wouldn't be
able to read the documents they would
look like nothing more than a bunch of
random numbers most security systems
rely on secure method for key exchange
to to communicate the encryption key to
the right place
however rapid increases in computational
power are putting at risk a number of
the key exchange methods we have today
consider one of the very widely used
systems today RSA when it was invented
in 1977 it was estimated that would take
40 quadrillion years to break a 426 bit
RSA key in 1994 just 17 years later the
code was broken as computers have become
more and more powerful we've had to use
larger and larger codes today we
routinely use 2048 of 4096 bits as you
can see code makers and breakers are
engaged in an ongoing battle to outwit
each other and when quantum computers
arrive in the next 10 to 15 years they
will even more rapidly crack the complex
mathematics that underlies many of our
encryption systems today indeed the
quantum computer is likely to turn a
present security castle into a mere
house of cards we have to find a way to
defend our castle there's been a growing
body of research in recent years looking
at using quantum effects to make
encryption stronger and they've been
some exciting breakthroughs remember
those three things important for
encryption high-quality keys secure key
exchange and a strong algorithm while
advances in science and engineering are
putting two of those three elements at
risk
first of all those keys
random numbers are the foundational
building blocks of encryption keys but
today they're not truly random currently
we construct encryption keys from
sequences of random numbers generated
from software so-called pseudo-random
numbers numbers generated by a program
or mathematical recipe will have some
perhaps subtle pattern to them the less
random the numbers are or in scientific
terms the less entropy they contain the
easier they are to predict recently
several casinos have been victims of a
creative attack the output of slot
machines was recorded over a period of
time and then analyzed this allowed the
cyber criminals to reverse-engineer the
pseudo-random number generator behind
the spinning wheels and allowed them
with high accuracy to predict the spins
of the wheels enabling them to make big
financial gains similar risks apply to
encryption keys so having a true random
number generator is essential for secure
encryption for years researchers have
been looking at building true random
number generators but most designs to
date either not random enough fast
enough or aren't easily repeatable but
the quantum world is truly random so it
makes sense to take advantage of this
intrinsic randomness devices that can
measure quantum effects can produce an
endless stream of random numbers at high
speed
coiling all those would be casino
criminals a select group of universities
and companies around the world are
focused on building true random number
generators at my company our quantum
random number generator started life on
a 2 meter by 1 meter optics table we
were then able to reduce it to a server
size box today
it's miniaturized into a PCI card that
plugs in to a standard computer
this is the world's fastest true random
number generator
it measures quantum effects to produce a
billion random numbers per second and
it's in use today to improve security at
cloud providers banks and government
agencies around the world but even with
a true random number generator we've
still got the second big cyber threat
the problem of secure key exchange
current key exchange techniques will not
stand up to a quantum computer the
quantum solution to this problem is
called quantum key distribution or qkd
which leverages a fundamental
counterintuitive characteristic of
quantum mechanics the very act of
looking at a quantum particle changes it
let me give you an example of how this
works consider again exchanging the key
the code for the lock with James Bond
except this time instead of a call to
give James the code we're going to use
quantum effects on a laser to carry the
code and send it over standard optic
fiber to James
we assume that dr. know is trying to
hack the exchange luckily dr. nose
attempts to intercept the quantum keys
while in transit we'll leave
fingerprints that James and you can
detect this allows those intercepted
keys to be discarded the keys which are
then retained can be used to provide
very strong data protection and because
the security is based on the fundamental
laws of physics a quantum computer or
indeed any future supercomputer will not
be able to break it my team and I are
collaborating with leading universities
and the defense sector to mature this
exciting technology into the next
generation of security products the
Internet of Things is
a hyper-connected era with 25 to 30
billion connected devices forecast by
2020 for the correct functioning of our
society in a IOT world trust in the
systems that support these connected
devices is vital we're betting that
quantum technologies will be essential
in providing this trust enabling us to
fully benefit from the amazing and
innovations that are going to so enrich
our lives
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]